aimez-vous l'Afrique
j'ai envie de vous entendre dire si vous
j'aime l'Afrique
vous savez il y a un certain monsieur
qui a écrit un livre
l'Afrique noire et mal parti
ce livre d'emblée nous a stigmatisé
alors que nous faisions nos premiers pas
en tant que nation au Purl indépendante
dans l'écosystème mondial
je sais que comme moi vous avez grandi
avec ce narratif négatif
aux informations que n'ai-je pas entendu
il y a une famille en Afrique de l'Est
on a trouvé un virus mortel qui vient du
Congo
des centaines de jeunes africains
sont retrouvés échoués morts sur les
côtes méditerranéennes
maladie pauvreté conflit le mort et le
sud de tels pays s'entretuent
combien d'entre vous ont entendu ça et
continue de l'entendre
dans les médias occidentaux que ce soit
la presse que ce soit à la télé
que ce soit même les films
à tel point que nous avons intériorisé
cela en nous jusqu'à en faire
notre credo
ce qui est beau ne peut pas être
africain vous voyez les vidéos qu'on
nous montre très souvent
on nous dit ah c'est trop beau ça ne
peut pas être en Afrique ou alors ça ne
peut être qu'en Afrique moins noire donc
plus blanche
cet Afrique plus civilisée
a contrario
on nous a approuvé
de louanges sur le rêve américain la
richesse culturelle
occidentale française
le seul espoir pour un Africain de
réussir c'est de sortir d'une université
occidentale comment peut-on s'aimer
quand on nous a appris à nous détester
moi je vais vous dire qu'il existe une
autre Afrique et c'est de cette Afrique
là que je vais vous parler
une Afrique des talents une Afrique des
réussites une Afrique des compétences
une Afrique de la créativité
une Afrique qui est moi
qui est vous qui nous qui chacun de nous
je suis nabufal je suis
africaine je suis humaine et je crois
que l'Afrique
et le continent qui va impacter ce
millénaire
pas avec des paroles en l'air pas avec
des fictions de cinéma hollywoodien
[Musique]
mais avec le concours de chacun de nous
à chaque fois que je voyage dans un pays
à travers le continent je rencontre des
personnes extraordinaires
c'est ainsi que vous allez voir à
l'écran la dame qui est avec moi tanti
crotum assez goûts depuis 25 ans
accompagnent des femmes les formes à la
fabrication du bogolin afin qu'elle
puisse être autonome ce sont des filles
mères ces femmes ont plus scolarisé des
centaines d'enfants qui aujourd'hui j'en
connais certains elle-même était veuve
c'est cinq enfants sont des cadres un de
ses fils et directeurs du Fonds culturel
africain
le jeune homme
qui est avec moi dans la brouette c'est
la vie
Lady Camara est né en France grandi en
France il a vécu à Londres Lady aurait
pu rester en Europe puisque le rêve est
européen Lady a fait le voyage inverse
l'a dit est venue il exploite 17
hectares à Maraca Congo sur la route de
Ségou à une heure de Bamako
Ladji exploite des melons des concombres
des pastèques
et il me dit tu sais j'ai même pas assez
pour le marché local la demande est
énorme
il y a
a quitté le monde de la banque où elle
était voué une grande carrière pour
faire donner vie à son rêve
d'inclusivité financière en Guinée
il y a Aïcha dem qui a écrit un livre ni
d'artiste Aïcha de se bat pour donner de
la visibilité aux artistes au Sénégal
toutes ces personnes pourquoi je vous en
parle parce que c'est sont ces personnes
comme vous et moi qui a l'ont transformé
le narratif de ce continent et pour
raconter cette histoire de progrès
d'Afrique qui réussit
d'Afrique ou loin des succès et non pas
que de la misère de la pauvreté des
conflits et la guerre je vais vous
parler d'une chose qui me tient à cœur
le personnel branding le pouvoir du
personnel branding vous en entendez
parler certainement mais je vais vous
dire comment
développer construire votre marque
personnelle ou personnelle branding en
quelques minutes
très simplement
Jeff Bezos fondateur d'Amazon dit votre
marque personnelle c'est ce que les gens
disent de vous
vous ici dans la salle vous ici qui nous
écoutez qu'est-ce que les gens disent de
vous choisissez trois mots qui viennent
souvent quand on vous décrit et ensuite
choisissez trois mots que vous aimeriez
entendre dire de vous en ce qui me
concerne j'aimerais qu'on dise de moi
que je suis inspirante impactante
riche là ça arrive c'est sur la route
je suis sur la route
et bienveillante
alors faites-le ensuite prenez votre
téléphone allez sur Google et regarder
ce que vous trouvez sur vous
quand vous tapez votre nom sur Google
est-ce que les photos que vous vous
trouvez
correspondent à l'image que vous voulez
donner
est-ce que le descriptif de votre
personne correspond à ce qui vous êtes à
ce que vous faites
dès le préalable ensuite on va aller sur
qui êtes-vous
quand vous vous connaissez quand vous
savez comment vous voulez vous projeter
au monde parce que je parle le pouvoir
de ce que l'on dit sur soi aux autres
les gens retiennent de nous ce que nous
leur disons
dans votre histoire familiale qu'est-ce
qui vous a motivé inspiré ou bloquer
mais qui vous a donné la force d'arriver
d'être qui vous êtes quels sont les
forces que vous avez en vous
quels sont les passions
qui vous motivent moi j'aime l'humain et
ma passion j'aime l'écriture j'aime la
lecture
quelles sont les personnes qui sont vos
influenceurs personnelles ces personnes
qui vous inspirent au quotidien
quelles sont les valeurs qui vous
donnent la force chaque matin de vous
lever et d'aller vers votre destin
au-delà de ça vous devez ensuite vous
poser la question pourquoi est-ce que je
fais ce que je fais quel est ma mission
de vie moi je dis que ma mission de vie
est de transformer le narratif de
l'Afrique une personne à la fois s'il
n'y a qu'une seule étoile qui brille
dans le ciel comment est-ce que ce
continent peut s'imposer et briller mais
si nous brillons tous
individuellement imaginez comment le
ciel sera étoilé brillant
comment vous faites ce que vous faites
quels sont vos expériences
quelle personne vous avez impacté
quelles expertises vous avez développé
prenez le temps d'écrire de réfléchir et
de revenir vers vous et vous verrez que
vous êtes plein de ressources et de
talent
ce continent ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui
va venir en faire le continent du
Millénaire c'est nous c'est vous je vous
invite à regarder votre voisin et votre
voisine parce que ce sont eux votre
voisin votre voisine qui vont changer la
donne et le narratif
on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
parler négativement je n'ai pas dit
qu'on soit irréaliste mais
puisons dans notre histoire collective
puisons dans tout ce que nous avons dans
nos cultures
puisons dans ce qui nous rend fier et
osons dire au monde qui nous sommes
assumons nos talents assumons notre
singularité
comme le dit felwin l'Afrique n'a
personne à rattrapé elle a ses modèles à
créer
il est important de savoir que nous
serons toujours africains
le personnel branding n'est pas fait
pour vous mettre en avant mais plutôt
pour mettre en avant les forces les
talents du continent et vous pouvez
raconter votre histoire en écrivant un
livre en acceptant des interviews
en acceptant d'être visible parce que
les 750 millions de jeunes africains qui
sont là ont besoin de nous pour être des
modèles afin qu'ils aient de l'espoir
s'ils vont en mer c'est parce qu'ils
sont désespérés ils ne vous voient pas
si on se cache on dit pas au monde qui
nous sommes nous sommes responsables de
la culture du buzz où les jeunes veulent
des likes sur la base de quoi aucune
compétence
ils n'ont rien accompli juste parce que
ils sont en train de danser sur un
réseau social on a besoin de voir des
gens qui créent on a besoin de voir un
tailleur qui est fier d'être ailleurs on
a besoin de voir des personnes qui sont
fiers de ce qu'elles font dans la
dignité dans l'intégrité dans le respect
chacun de vous ici dans son
environnement respectif impact inspire
avec foi et résilience
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à être
l'Africain qui va porter le millénaire
est-ce que vous êtes prêts je veux vous
entendre me dire oui
de travail personne ne le fera à notre
place nous devons investir les
différentes plateformes qui existent
vous savez les réseaux sociaux on en
parle ça peut être quelque chose de
négatif mais pour moi c'est quelque
chose de positif ça permet de parler de
l'Afrique ou de la des frontières
ça permet de voir de raconter nos
histoires différemment pendant que je
parle nous sommes en direct
ces vidéos seront retransmises vous
savez il y a des gens qui n'ont pas vu
des Africains comme vous et moi
je me rappelle quand j'allais en
vacances en Angleterre aux États-Unis tu
habites dans un arbre j'ai dit non ils
ne savent pas parce que nous ne nous
montrons pas nous avons laissé les
autres prendre le pas sur notre histoire
nous avons laissé les autres raconter
nos histoires nous avons laissé les
autres nous donner le courage de nous
détester
[Musique]
et vous le vivez au quotidien quand on
recommande un Africain non non
l'Africain lui-même va dire non non
pardon moi tu sais les Africains je veux
pas parce que tu sais comment on est on
est comment
et partout pareil
la malhonnêteté
l'incompétence elle est universelle elle
n'est pas africaine pourquoi est-ce
qu'on veut se l'approprier
approprions-nous nos compétences notre
brillance nos intelligences
si nous ne le faisons pas qui va le
faire avec notre place plus personne ne
viendra nous sauver il est temps
aujourd'hui d'oser prendre la voix et
dire je suis un artiste je suis un
entrepreneur et je vais aller dans une
école je vais parler de mon histoire je
vais dire qui je suis il faut arrêter
non mes parents c'est Notre culture
c'est vrai on nous a dit de pour vivre
revivons cachés ça ça marchait avant ça
ne marche plus pour ce millénaire on ne
peut plus vivre caché parce que nous
sommes les modèles que la génération
future
nous sommes porteurs d'espoir nous
sommes les vecteurs de progrès
c'est l'Africain individuellement et non
on va plus parler de gouvernance on va
parler de personnes qui changent le
monde de personnes qui impactent le
continent
et ces personnes c'est nous
je voudrais vraiment que vous preniez le
l'engagement aujourd'hui
[Musique]
de prendre votre pouvoir d'assumer vos
compétences d'assumer votre brillance
parce que quand vous vous Briez vous
faites briller tout le continent
l'Afrique on dit que c'est le perso de
l'humanité mais l'Afrique est aussi
l'avenir de l'humanité merci